look in the end I have come to the
conclusion that because of concerns for
really the uncertainty of leaving what
it would mean for business I will vote
for remain but I have to say I've not
been particularly impressed by the
debate on either side I don't feel that
the facts and the arguments have really
come through I think it's left a lot of
my constituents a lot of the public
uncertain and it's been a very difficult
decision to reach partly as a result
well yes and you and you say that really
it came down to what's good for business
and they'll be plenty that won't agree
with you aren't they just today Lord
Bamford who has 6,000 employees and a
JCB has said that the UK is a trading
nation that can stand on its own two
feet that you'll have lots of people
that won't agree like that particular
decision yeah I look at he's a
successful business person I completely
agree that there is absolutely a
feasible route for us outside of Europe
and that is why like on some days I had
felt closer to leave other days closer
to remain and it has been as the same
very difficult for me surprisingly
agonizing choice between leavin remain I
to get fed up with Europe with the EU
with them taking on too many conferences
and telling us what to do on the other
hand there can be no doubt that if it
comes down to uncertainty of course it's
more uncertain to leave because you know
that's the route that we don't know and
my principal concern therefore is what
that means for British business how easy
would it in fat be to negotiate those
trade deals with 27 other countries and
you know what that then means for
British jobs as I say i've not been
terribly impressed by the campaign on on
either side i haven't really found that
it's been getting to the bottom of the
facts i think it's been to personality
driven all the rest of it so this has
been a difficult decision but in the end
I think my constituents have a right to
know know what I will do and I've
reached that decision so I thought it
best to say something oh yes and
essentially that you criticize the
campaign's on both sides what do you
think it's done to the Conservative
Party because language has got pretty
strong hasn't it between what's
essentially a split party
well it has and I think that's a real
shame and I'm afraid to say it's
actually that's happened even with
people who should know better I I think
and speaking as a former Conservative
Party Chairman it seems to me this EU
referendum of course is an enormous
decision facing the country that's why
it's such a difficult decision for
people to make but in the end the
Conservative Party will need to be there
to take the country forward and I do
appeal to colleagues as a former
Conservative Party Chairman to not only
be you know in this final fortnight
careful with language and the rest of it
but also afterwards we're going to have
to come together and work for the good
of the nation and so I think it's really
important that we do remember that this
is important there will still be work to
be done for this country afterwards and
so you know I appeal to conservatives to
remember which other side of this debate
we're all on and it does divide people
and we will have to work together
afterwards